okay everyone thanks so much for being
here um for our second talk of uh this
this three uh talk afternoon Series so
um as someone who's worked in machine
learning um and for any of you guys
working in machine learning you may know
that the two most feared words can
sometimes be in production um so this is
I'm personally really excited for this
one because LMS haven't existed for too
long so learning how uh from Emily draw
how to put them into production should
be a really fascinating topic so welcome
thank
you thank you so much for such a nice
introduction I'm really happy to be here
today and uh I believe well monitoring
is boring like everyone prefer to raise
our train models not to monitor them but
I believe you'll enjoy some information
about how we can actually set up
monitoring for NLP and large language
models in production
uh just a brief introduction um my name
is Emily I'm co-founder and CTO of
evidently AI which is a startup where we
buil open source tool to monitor
validate and test machine learning
models of course including large
language models and prior to that I
worked as a data engineer to help
companies train deploy and monitor
machine learning models so I will rather
speak from that experience again during
the deployment models
myself uh well we all know that train a
good model including Transformer is a
quite tough task by itself and then we
need to deploy it to production which
also is not that obvious but
unfortunately our job doesn't stop there
right we need to make sure that our
model is safe and sound and produce
valuable data valuable output because
well when we use some model in
production each failure cost us
something so we needs to make sure that
everything works well luckily we have a
years of experience of having software
Solutions production so pretty much we
can reuse quite a lot of monitoring
architecture from the uh standard
services like uh I mean there are a lot
of metrics like service Health up time
memory usage latency Etc which we
definitely should track for our machine
learning based serves um as well but
here we have extra layer or of
complexity because we need to also
monitor for data health monitor for
models quality and look for metrics like
data drift um model quality depending on
the problem statement well it's quite a
lot and when it comes to llms it's also
quite a lot of things that we need to
look for for example there can be quite
a lot of technical errors like wrong
encodings or maybe unexpected language
maybe there are some uh technical bugs
in our data processing pipelines or
maybe there are just some data shifts
because our models are not live in the
vacuum right there are a lot of things
that can change outside and there might
be new topics or maybe the change of the
shares of different topics so it's very
important to track it as well pretty
often especially when it comes to using
of Transformers we use some thirdparty
models through the apis and it's pretty
important to check for model behaviors
because if this model has been retrained
for example or updated then probably you
can face some issues on your subset of
queries you use this transformer for so
it's pretty important to track for Model
Behavior shifts and well model attacks
are quite interesting and popular noways
so sometimes you face things like prompt
injections or some other serial use this
is why it's quite important to keep
track on our models and well
hallucinations is also very wellknown
problem when our model produces some um
unrealistic output and that's also not
that good right so this is why we really
care about about models quality and data
quality as well so how to prepare again
monitoring but we need to make sure that
we have very clear vision and
expectations of what we actually want to
have from our monitoring and well I
believe there are quite a lot of
expectations but these three are quite
important first is like meaningful
metrics because well nowadays we have a
lot of tools which helps us to calculate
like thousands or even more different
statistics but if you will check for all
possible let's say statistics we can
calculate on top of our row data we will
be easily snowed under by ton of false
alerts and I believe it will be very
similar to like just not having any
monitoring because well if you have
alerts every minute I would say no one
really care about them so it's pretty
important to select only meaningful
metrics the second thing is uh alerting
policy this very important to uh Define
uh right thresholds for each metrix and
very clear uh action policy it can be
very different things for example you
might uh want to send a specific object
to the manual review or maybe fall back
from machine learning model to some
other system for example rule based or
maybe trigger retraining process
sometimes we maybe want just to send a
message to our data engineer with some
data and some statistics to potentially
fix the issue later but it's very
important to have this connction between
the metrix and action policy and finally
when we for example deal with large
language models sometimes it's sometimes
it's not that obvious how to react to
different uh metrics beyond the
thresholds and this is why it's pretty
important to include enough information
in our alert I mean to provide some
context which will help to figure out
what's going on with the model and
potentially fix the issue faster so this
is why context with a lot of maybe not a
lot of but with some statistics and some
visual information like like maybe
distributions is quite important to
solve issue fasters at least pretty
often we might save some time from our
data engineering team to grab some logs
and calculate all the statistics ourself
so it's like meaningful metrics action
policy and enough context well having
this in mind let's start to discuss what
actually we can monitor for our machine
learning models especially a large
language models so um I would say that
in case you're lucky enough to have a
direct signal which tells you how good
your model is it's better to start from
it I mean if you have for example
immediate feedback and you do not need
to wait to get your delayed feedback
then you can pretty fast calculate Anye
equality Matrix which is relevant to you
for example like Precision recall maybe
me absolute error whatever makes sense
for your problem statement but but
unfortunately um it happens pretty
rarely and in many cases we just do not
have this direct signal without any time
delay and unfortunately we need to come
up with some other matrics and here we
have some proxy matric in most cases the
data quality Matrix do really help
because well if there is something wrong
with the data then probably the model
might react somehow unexpectedly so it
doesn't necessarily mean that we will
have some problem with the model output
but potentially we will so uh data
quality is very important and luckily
the input data is something we always
have at hands right and this is why it's
quite important to calculate some data
quality metrics and I'm going to expand
on this topic a little bit later
together with input features we always
have the output of our models right
without any like almost without any
delay and in this case it makes sense to
analyze this output as well and
calculate things like prediction d dri
for example or uh other types of model
output drift it helps us to see whether
there are some unexpected shifts and
maybe trigger some alerts to manually
check what's going on well proxy metrics
are very important and when it comes to
large language models I believe it's a
little bit more complicated compared to
direct signal this is why I'm going to
focus on proxy metric more because when
it comes to direct signal I believe
anyone like know what to calculate so
how to deal with a structured data just
to start uh from the structured data
when we have some tabular data we can
easily analyze each individual feature
right we can calculate something like
share of missing values we can calculate
tones of metrics about some range
violations especially for numerical
features for categorical we can
calculate the proportion of different
categories compare um check that the
main category is exactly what they
expected compare distributions to
calculate drift so it's all pretty
well-known techniques which we can use
to like make sure that our data has good
good quality but when it comes to
unstructured data it's not that
straightforward right so we need to
somehow reprocess those data to make
sure that we can analy it for data
quality and data drift so well pretty
often we even deal with multimodal data
especially when it's the data sets
related to for example products review
or chats or maybe some support tickets
or complaints we definitely would have
roow text there but together with roow
text we will also have some data uh
related to things like maybe countries
from where the query comes or maybe
operation system product category a lot
of different uh structured data which
are pretty valuable and definitely we
want to keep both unstructured and
structured data in our data set so this
is why sometimes we need to uh design
the monitoring for multi model data sets
as well so now finally to monitoring so
what to monitor for unstructured data
well today I'm going to introduce to you
three main strategies which I believe
works well in practice and finally uh
quickly touch a point about multimodel
data sets because I believe sometimes
it's uh like well also quite important
so um those three main strategies there
are more strategies of course but I
believe these three works are really
good so first is Monitor Rotex data if
you have an access to such data second
is create some descriptors and finally
um we can monitor embeddings as well and
let's uh go through them one by one so
first is monitoring for RO text Data
well for RO Text data we can build quite
a lot of things but I would like to
underline two main topics which I really
like the first is modelbased drift
detection because because for RO text we
are lucky enough uh and we can build
very well um binary classification model
based on the back of wordss text
representation and this is really cool
because if you use the back of wordss
features based on our text then we can
train any interpretable model for
example it's well known in the industry
that binary logistic regression is very
good for um text right and if you train
this model to distinguish between the
reference data set and the reference is
the data set where we are happy with the
model quality for example we can
handpick this data set with respect to
our problem statement and maybe the main
area specifics maybe hand pick some
queries maybe some specific text or just
take the data set from the validation
phase and we can compare uh this data
set to the new batch of data for example
the one we collected during the day
right and well what we can do we can
definitely build the binary
classification model then if you use
logistic progression we can check the uh
words with the highest weight and it
will give us a lot of intuition about
what's going on so what is the source of
the differences from our text for
example if in the current data set we
see that there are a lot of words like
disappointed OD said size maybe uh and
when it comes to reference data set we
see some words like stunning perfect
complement slowly then probably the
drift the difference of our text comes
from the sentiment not from the text
size or maybe new additional topics well
that's questionable but still we can
create a lot of hypothesis of what's
going on this is why I like this uh way
to calculate drift on top of our text
really well and luckily logistic
regression really works good so in this
case as a metric score it's good to use
some um quality of your model uh and I
would say something like receiver
reparation curve area under the curve
Works quite quite well but just make
sure that you created a very good like
threshold because well we need to come
up with the threshold what is a good
model or and what is bad model I mean
what is model is confidence to
distinguish between reference and
current data set does it mean that we
need to have our area under the curve
just higher than uh 50% or something
else so it depends of course on the um
frequency of alerts you want to get uh
because of the text drift and there is
one another way how we can potentially
do it and instead of binary
classification model you could use topic
modeling to track what are the topics in
your text I would say it's a little bit
more tricky because well uh we know
that I would say all unsupervised yeah
pretty all unsupervised problem
statements are incorrect from the MTH
point of view right because there are no
like correct solution and they cannot
like
say uh what is the right structure of
our data right uh we can tell uh what
are the right topics this is why you
would probably spend quite a lot of time
into getting the right clustering model
which makes sense from the problem
statement point of view and well but if
you ready to invest some time into
building such model you can then apply
your cluster in model to new bunch of
texts and just track the topic you have
uh the topics I mean so you can compare
the sizes of topics you can check for
new topics or maybe check for some
topics you lost and this is how you can
treat your drift good news is that if
topics are meaningful then you still can
generate some insights of what's going
on and what has changed in your text so
this is why I really like to use the r
text for monitoring because you can
easily come up with good ideas of what's
going on and potentially fix uh some
problems faster so that's I believe the
most interesting things we can monitor
on top of the row
data the second strategy is to turn
unstructured data into structured and it
will works just wonderful for texts why
so just because if you have an access to
the row text we can basically calculate
a lot of Statistics we can calculate
text drift on sorry text length we can
calculate the share of out of vocabulary
words we can apply some sentiment models
to each object I mean each row text and
by doing that we actually can create
some descriptors which are quite similar
to just numerical or categorical
features like for example if you have
pretty specific problem statement for
example you use some Transformers like
GPT to produce some output you might
want to create very specific transformer
for example you might want to like check
whether the output from your Transformer
is correct HTML or is correct python
code or maybe it's correct Json right
and this is also descriptor because
basically what you do is you apply your
text uh you let's say you first create a
prompt automatically then you send it to
Transformer then you receive the answer
and you just check uh with some third
party methods whether it's it is correct
Json or not and the results of that of
such check is the binary um feature
binary descriptor just true or false
correct Json or not correct Json and by
doing that you create structured
representation of your text and as soon
as we have some structured
representation what can we do we can
basically track any matric you be like
so that's the example how it looks like
in evidently so basically that's a
dashboard and the idea is super
straightforward now you have numerical
and categorical values and you can come
up with any rule based checks for
example you like for example min max
ranges for text length or maybe some uh
expectations of share of non-letter
symbols on o we or maybe share of
non-correct Json uh from the output of
your model so whatever you like and now
it's like structured data so we can use
any method we can use for numerical data
or categorical one like correlations
between for example some descriptors and
the target we can track drift right and
it's also will be very insightful
especially if you invested enough time
into building uh and calculating the
right um the
scriptures so finally when it comes to
embeddings it's quite hard to create
something good from the interpretation
point of view because well it's
embeddings unfortunately but we still
can do quite a lot of nice things for
example we can treat embeddings like a
object I mean process text like an
object in high dimensional space and uh
having this in mind we can use a lot of
distance-based metrics to calculate the
drift like for example what we can do um
is yeah we can take the vectors from the
reference data set then average them to
get a single Vector then we can do the
same for the current data set and just
calculate any distance metric between
those two vectors like Ean C sign
whatever you like and this will be you
like aggregated estimation of drift of
course no interpretation unfortunately
but it's still it will be numerical
value you can track and see whether you
whether it's increased or decreased or
maybe um with help of experiments you
can even set up a good threshold for
this and finally there are some more
metrics which uh methods which we can
apply to embeddings for example we can
also build a domain classifier which
will try to solve binary classification
problem and distinguish vectors from
reference and the current well no
interpretation unfortunately but still
the quality of the model will tell us
what is the confidence of the model um
for like separating between the
reference and current data which is also
quite good and finally there are some uh
like Engineers who prefer to calculate
the share of drifted components of
beddings again it's quite hard to
interpret them because how to interpret
that like fifth component of our edding
has drifted well nothing right but at
least we can check the share of drifted
components and by having this value
somehow communicate
the confidence that we do have data
drift in our edings so that's also quite
interesting and finally I would say a
couple of words how we can deal with
some multimodal data and here the
strategies will be very similar to what
we just did for the text so we can
either split data by type turn all the
data to unstructured or turn all the
data to structured so I believe that's
the most practical ways to solve it so
first is really straightforward for
example if you want to calculate data
drift for your multimodal data set what
you can do is to for example calculate
the drift for each individual feature
from the structured part of your data
then calculate drift with help of for
example binary classifier for your text
and then calculate share of drifted
features right so that's how you can
process it separately and of course well
uh pretty same goes for other
metrics the second strategy is to create
somehow a joint structure data set uh
which contains only numerical
categorical maybe some binary features
but it's also categorical so uh yeah
that's what we can do as well I do
really like this method because by doing
that you firstly you need to reprocess
your roow text it will gives you some
descriptores and descriptores are
structured data right it SS a table
basically this means that you can join
your descriptor to the features and work
only with structured data and here again
you can use a lot of Statistics like
missing values some maybe range
violations for numerical features uh
share of specific categories data drift
and whatever you need on top of your
joint representation of data set and
well descriptors are very meaningful
because you know what each descriptor
means so it's very good to like
interpret what has
changed third Strat is to like try to
move you from multimodal data set to the
unstructured one I don't know why I call
edings Un structured just just because
it's hard to interpret them I would say
so so in this case I would suggest to
like imagine that our uh structured part
of the data set like those uh method
data are like additional components of
the embeddings so it will basically move
us to the more like High dimensional
space where we have some additional
components right so and in this case we
can just join our embeddings with our
features and try to use for example
binary classification model to like
distinguish between the reference and
current data set so from this point of
view you will be able to get this
aggregated estimation of the confidence
that there is a drift but uh you will
lose some interpretation unfortunately
but that's the cost of having the
integral estimation of drift for the
whole data
set uh well just final words about the
model's output because it's also very
important I personally believe that the
model output drift is very strong signal
of potential problems of your with your
model so uh when it comes to structured
output like labels in case of
classification problem or maybe a
numerical value if you solve regression
problem we all know what to do we just
need to select this suitable statistical
tests or maybe distance metric
probabilistic distance metric of course
and just evaluate the difference between
the distributions but what if our output
is also unstructured like for example
text from the
transformer in this case we also can
monitor the drift because we just
discussed that for example we easily can
create some descriptors and check for
drif and descriptors right and I would
really really suggest you to start from
this part of monitoring if you just
started to work with large language
models because the drift in like input
data is let's say less uh predictable in
terms of the potential major issue with
the whole model compared to the predic
the uh output drift so the output drift
is very good start to uh monitor the
quality of your unstructured data so
well suming up uh monitoring is
something we really need to implement
when we have Production Services I
believe uh that pretty straightforward
but even if you have some unstructured
data like text you shouldn't just ignore
this part of data in your monitoring
because we actually can do quite a lot
of things when you have Ro Text data we
know what to do we can build the main
classification model or calculate some
descriptores and it will be so good in
terms of interpretability so I would
really suggest to do that you will
immediately see what exactly has changed
in your data if you dealing withm Bings
which is quite often case well in this
case we also have some distance-based
models no interpretability but at least
numerical estimation of the drift size
and finally if you have a multimodel
data set I would suggest to like move
this task to one of the following either
uh go to like Bings and calculate drift
using some distance metrix or go for uh
descriptores and create the joint
structured representation of your data
set and then calculate quality Matrix
and drift Matrix which works for your
data set so uh basically that's all I
wanted to share with you I believe
you're in time and yeah happy to answer
any questions or just discuss
anything